bonjour france avec sa mère
bonjour merci beaucoup vous êtes le
maire de dijon
située dans une région en zone rouge
quelle est la situation pour commencer
quelle est la situation dans votre
région dans la ville dans le département
les choses s'améliorent progressivement
et et même depuis quelques jours très
rapidement donc il ya une nette
amélioration il n'y a plus de mille
décès est très très peu de nouvelles
entrées de patients suspects ou qu'ovide
est par contre des sorties qui
s'accélère donc je pense qu'on est sur
le chemin si les choses continuent comme
ça pour verdir pour se retrouver en
verre moi j'ai toujours pensé que pour
que le déconfinement je passe bien comme
le confinement il fallait faire appel à
la responsabilité des gens plus que
j'avais à dire à l'infantilisation qu'on
a pu connaître des soins à travers
quelques propos ministériels donc donc
on appelle les gens à la responsabilité
on leur à leur a distribué des masques
on leur donne les consignes on a mis en
place un certain nombre de protocoles on
le fait savoir
donc ça se passe bien y compris dans les
transports en commun même si comment
dire l'engourdissement est encore un peu
là c'est assez longue ça reprend
lentement progressivement mais je
reprends ma fonction je pas jeter de la
pierre c'est pas facile hein on est
quand même dans une situation
extrêmement compliquée extrêmement
difficile non ce qui me gêne est le plus
c'était des propos qui étaient j'allais
dire dangereusement alarmiste et qui
crée de l'anxiété des propos monsieur
eugène de la peur et je vais vous donner
un exemple assez simple on a décidé de
rouvrir les écoles à dijon fait tout
pour que ça se passe bien on teste le
nombre de parents qui vont mettre leurs
enfants à l'école par
enfin de soignants bien évidemment et on
a un taux de réponse de l'ordre de 28%
donc on se dit c'est c'est bien ça
commence bien
et puis monsieur véran dit mme ysebaert
en dit l'autre jour
attention si si ça si vous tenez pas
bien on va être obligé de reconfirmer et
hop
dix pour cent des parents se disent oh
la la c'est reprend en fait prendre des
risques à nos enfants etc
et du coup ça a chuté à 12% ou 14 cents
j'ai fait le tour d'écolière bon voilà
donc il faut pas de tenir des propos
comme ça ça s'appelle l'infantilisation
faut faire appel à la responsabilisation
n'est pas n'est pas la menace
attention attention voilà donc c'est
bizarre il ya eu deux trois déclarations
comme ça où des déclarations aussi
bizarre que qui sont contre productives
que celle de nice bloquèrent quand il
dit finalement c'est moins dangereux
d'aller à l'école que de passer deux
mois pour finir chez soi alors c'est
vraiment là j'ai envie de dire au
premier ministre
allez allez vous reprendre en main cette
communication monde est le président de
la république l'a annoncé je me suis dit
qu'il fallait il fallait avancer il
fallait aller s'en sortir
progressivement il fallait dire aux gens
comment on pouvait faire les choses bien
fallait les rassurer donc non non au
contraire on a été très très
volontariste même un peu trop puisque
j'avais annoncé que rouvrirait comme
l'avait dit blanc caire en cp au cm2 et
en grande section maternelle le 12 mai
puis qu'on m'a dit qu'il y avait un jour
de prérentrée
donc j'avais prévenu les parents que ce
serait le 12 mai europe pendant qu'on
était en train on avait envoyé un sms à
tout le monde pour 10 euros prix de 12
mais qu on nous avait annoncé le 14 mai
bien c'est des petites choses comme ça
si on nous laissait un peu plus de la
capacité de décider sur le terrain en
fonction de ce qu'on voit la france
irait mieux aujourd'hui personne sur
cette décentralisation mais sur la
responsabilité des écoles est ce que
vous vous êtes inquiet sur d'éventuels
points sur les i
vous avez prises ou est ce que vous
dites la loi nous protège suffisamment
c'est un bon compromis qui a été trouvé
auparavant
mais moi je pense est un bon compromis
j'étais pas inquiet personnellement mais
je comprends que des maires de plus
petites communes tus l'aide du prochain
peut-être dû de celui ou de celle qui
serait amené à porter plainte
par exemple la loi fauchon avait quand
même un caractère protecteur et donc le
compromis qui a été trouvé un bon
compromis et je ne suis pas
personnellement inquiète d'ailleurs on
parle beaucoup de ces plaintes
bon elles n'ont pas beaucoup de suite
la question qui se passe à l'ouverture
alors j'ai ce débat quasiment tous les
jours avec le préfet puisque il ya un
échange qui se passe avec avec le préfet
j'ai géré ouvert des espaces qu'ils
n'étaient pas des parcs et jardins mais
qu'ils étaient des lieux de promenade
on a un grand lac à dijon donc on peut à
nouveau aller se promener autour du lac
en respectant les gestes barrière je
rappelle à chaque fois on a des combes
et des grands espaces urbains verne qui
ne sont pas des parcs au sens parc
urbain
donc cela sont rouverts ouvert et puis
il ya les jardins des grands jardins
urbains
j'essaie de dire au préfet mais il m'a
dit que le décret était tellement
aussillon ont des décrets des protocoles
et 63 pages de l'éducation nationale de
protocoles et donc il y il me dit à nos
le décret ne me le permet pas pour le
moment
enfin en haut des bars ces protocoles
pour ça a donné des arguments à des gens
qui voulaient pas par exemple dans
l'école on a eu quelques directeurs
d'école très peu bien 85e 83 écoles à
dijon donc il ya des directeurs d'école
radio la la la la
vous n'avez pas mis le le bidon du gel
hydroalcoolique à l'entrée de là il
fallait le mettre à l'entrée du couloir
allant dans ces conditions peu pour
ouvrir quand même
voilà donc il ya eu aussi ça avec un
protocole qui était comme de dire il
faut quatre mètres carrés par enfant
quand l'enfant est content saumur en fin
da souvent dans cet exemple mais
tellement drôle j'avais dû oublier
qu'aux von poehl qui avaient des murs
d'une salle de classe
un mot sur la question des masques
puisque ça aussi ça jouer pendant ce
continent est ce que pour vous ça a été
facile de vous en procurer ce que vous
avez été aidées par l'état parce qu'au
contraire le maire a dû palier
défaillance de l'état sur cette question
moi j'ai cru au début que quand le
président de la république actuel des
masques distribués par l'état j'habite
eu d'écouté des positions de la public
quel qu'il soit voilà et donc qu'on n'a
pas une mascotte l'état aucun bien
évidemment l'état en ce moment fourni
des masques au personnel soignant il a
toujours fait ça au personnel soignant
et puis maintenant un peu mieux dans les
ehpad etc
mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont pu blique
question citoyens personnel non là il
n'y a pas eu de l'état et donc c'était
assez difficile c'est vrai on a eu une
première commande avec la région d'un
million de masques chirurgicaux
donc cela je les gardais on avait en
stock nous on n'avait pas brûlé nos
stocks
donc on avait gardé nos stocks h1n1 ils
ont bien fonctionné on en a distribué
dans les ehpad
il ya 37 epa dha dans la métropole à
tous les personnels étaient très heureux
dans des cliniques privées
donc on a utilisé le premier stock pour
cette soixante dix mille je crois
soixante mille masques en stock
enfin au début ça nous a aidés on a
commandé des masques chirurgicaux est un
région saint thélo mais on arrivait en
récupérer un million il ya une dizaine
de jours et puis j'ai commandé j'avais
commandé des masques lavables jetables
et là je dois dire que j'ai été très
heureux de voir la solidarité qui
existait entre les mères puisque j'avais
promis à la population deux masques
lavables et je n'en avais pas assez
alors que ce que j'ai fait j'ai appelé
des amis maires et je voudrais le rendre
ici hommage de maire de nice christian
estrosi et m'a proposé 35 mille masques
qu'ils avaient en plus donc il les a
avancées et distribuer à la population
le maire de cannes david lisnard nous a
aussi donné presque trente mille masques
25 mille masques
il y avait qu un petit problème c'est
assez drôle c'est qu'ils aient marqué
cannes dessus et qu'il fait des strips
tout ça est et comme les revers
socialiste un ami qui est pas très loin
qui à bourg en bresse qui m'a donné ce
qui lui restait cinq mille images
c'est donc voyez grâce à ça qui a été un
complément des masques et on avait
commandé qui avait du mal à arriver
on a pu distribuer deux masques à tout
le monde ce week-end ça s'est très bien
passé entre les deux questions c'est la
question la question
explications qu est ce que vous vous
êtes candidat cette expérimentation
j'attends j'attends de voir si les
candidats qui commence à toulouse et qui
nous dira comment ça se passe après non
je fais attention je suis pour que
effectivement il y ait dans le secret
médical a suivi de ceux qui ont pu
contacter qui ont été testées boîte mais
bien sûr dans un endroit confiné
je suis pour ça mais je suis très
attentif à tout ce qui touche aux
libertés individuelles
donc je suis très prudent sur ce sujet
très prudent ça pose maintenant la
question du redémarrage redémarrage
économique
elle a dit ian entendu dans philippe
qu'il était favorable à une ouverture
des cafés des restaurants dans les zones
vertes à partir du 2 juin dijon et en
zone rouge est ce que vous dites il faut
aussi ouvrir c'est sûr j'ai dit mais
j'espère qu'on passe quand vous on
devait déjà ça nous arrangerait mais oui
on est on est très vigilants à dijon il
ya 270 resteront dans le centre ville en
a partout et donc on peut leur donner
des conditions de travail plus favorable
on peut leur permettre d'étendre les
terrasses sans qu'ils aient à payer de
droits d'occupation du domaine public
donc on est en contact permanent avec la
profession avec lui avec lui et me h
et c est donc moins loin si on le peut
et puis il ya ceux qui disent ne faut
pas prendre trop de risques des
restaurants des restaurateurs il faut
vraiment qu'on ait un protocole nous
aussi distille une sorte de garantie
nous sommes voilà nous sommes habilités
à ouvrir donc on discute mais je pense
ça serait bien on pourra pas ne pas
ouvrir
les cafés les restaurants dans des
conditions particulières bien évidemment
mais les sujets suivants
je suis favorable à ce que l'activité
économique redémarre
je pense que c'est une catastrophe qu'il
attend si nous ne faisons pas des
efforts pour faire redémarrer l'économie
à cet égard vous voyez on a continué à
délivrer des permis de construire en
temps masqué pendant pendant sept ans
dans le service de la métropole est
l'état n'a pas réuni les commissions de
sécurité et donc on veut pas rouvrir
donc j'ai dit au préfet il faut quand
même bouger un peu aussi des services de
l'état n'y a pas que les services des
métropoles ou des mairies vous êtes
président a également de la fédération
nationale des élus socialistes sur les
finances des collectivités alors là en
plus je suis président de la commission
des finances de france urbaine donc je
suis en contact parce que par le par
l'association fonction des notions
contact vision souvent avec darmanin
gérald darmanin et puis aussi avec jean
rené cazeneuve à l'assemblée nationale
qui s'occupait bien sûr des finances des
collectivités locales oui on est très
inquiet très inquiet il ya une
proposition qui est sur la table
aujourd'hui qui est la nôtre elle peut
sembler maximaliste mais il faut
commencer par là si on veut être entendu
et donc c'est de nationaliser d'avoir
comme sur deux budgets annexes qu'ovide
ou un compte dédié qu'ovide est dedans
de mettre toutes les dépenses qu'ovide
et à côté aussi toutes les recettes
liées ou kobe et donc ça ça va faire un
total qui va d'après les premières
estimations le mode d'expression à la
louche entre eux c'est 8 10 milliards et
donc on dit à l'état il faut nous
compenser les 8 10 milliards pour
l'ensemble des collectivités et donc 8
10 milliards mais l'essentiel est écrit
par les communes et les métropoles les
agglomérations des opci
donc on la défend nous compenser en
compensation moi j'ai discuté avec
gérald darmanin qui étaient intéressés
par ce qu'on dit et l'a pas pris
d'engagement dans une écoute elle est
donc en compensation si on nous rétablit
ou si on nous maintient nos dépenses eux
nos dépenses et nos recettes de voilà
sur notre capacité d'investissement nous
on est prêt à appuyer abonder un fonds
que l'état devra créer dans la relance
pour par exemple un grand grand grand
comment dire un grand fonds de relance
sur l'isolation thermique des bâtiments
ça c'est du verdissement de l'économie
c'est absolument indispensable ça
redonne du travail tout de suite il faut
s'imaginer que dans une métropole comme
disons qu'une petite métropole avec 260
mille habitants il ya onze mille emplois
liés à la production au bâtiment et aux
travaux publics
donc il faut absolument qu au 6 mai pour
six mais il faut qu'on ait les moyens de
le faire et on est prêt à amender ce que
l'état nous demandera à condition qu'ils
nous accompagnent quand on voit les
décisions qui ont été lourdes à
apprendre je suppose financièrement on
va exploser la dette de l'état
on se dit il sans vouloir en rajouter
que 8 ou 10 milliards de plus ou de
moins ça changera pas grand chose
justement est ce que vous dites que de
cette crise doit être à nouveau souffle
de décentralisation notamment dans la 3d
oui même elle serait presque à reprendre
complètement cette voie d'abord on
savait pas bien ce qui a fait 2 dans la
faible coût de réunions avec nous elle a
été toujours en contact avec nous pas de
problème mais il faut reprendre tout ça
on s'aperçoit quand même que les alors
je ne dis pas de passer à la république
fédérale mais on s'aperçoit que la ou
les landes et les régions ont plus de
pouvoir
eh bien ça a mieux marché il y a dans ce
pays il ya des silos de des ministères
qui sut qui fonctionne en silo la santé
la rs l'éducation nationale même les
préfets ne peuvent plus rentrer dedans
et ils sont incapables de gérer la
logistique depuis le niveau national on
l'a vu il ya tard mais qui est capable
de faire la logistique dans des bonnes
conditions
mais les décisions nationales comme ça
sur l'ensemble du territoire
mais je trouve ça même puisque ça je
trouve ça stupide pour dire la vérité
c'est grave ce grave parce que c'est
déresponsabilisant je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est infantilisant et et puis
on va pas prendre quand même les maires
pour
wenger on sait très bien agir en
responsabilité
d'ailleurs on peut être responsable donc
voila moi je je plaide pour un plus que
la décentralisation une compréhension
différente du territoire on peut plus
avoir des lois des lois-cadres on peut
pas avoir des lois avec des décrets
d'ailleurs sont pas toujours pris dans
les temps où il faudrait qu'il soit prix
qui s'applique de manière uniforme sur
le territoire franchement la lozère et
et c'est pas le nord séné ces deux
départements différents dont sept
enfants n'auront pas compris ça et
collet ne sera pas agir avec plus de
liberté bien on n'avancera pas échappé
ni est surchargé de cette bureaucratie
centrale se pose maintenant la question
des municipal du second tour qu'on soit
il sait tenir le plus tôt possible le
plus tôt car oui en juin bien sûr
vraisemblablement en juin
enfin j'imagine pas qu'on puisse les
enfants aillent à l'école
j'espère les bars restaurants etc soit
rouvert qu'on puisse aller faire ses
courses s'empiler dans l'essonne
commerciaux sans respecter des fois les
gestes barrières et puis qu'on puisse
pas aller voter il faut il faut sortir
la démocratie à la couche qui très gêné
d'ailleurs quand je vois des élus qu'ils
ont c'est pas le moment de parler de les
élections non mais franchement et c'est
pas quelque chose de sale la démocratie
et la démocratie locale
ll est vital pour la république et vous
savez c c'est dans les pays où il n'ya
pas de démocratie locale qu'on a deux
dictatures donc la démocratie locale oui
le second tour oui il ya un argument
économique majeure je veux pas insister
dessus mais il est essentiel si nous
voulons une autre intercommunalité
puisse relancer participer au plan de
relance
être là il faut qu'on puisse prendre des
décisions en responsabilité moi je me
sentirais pas j'allais le dire avec la
validation démocratique
si si je ne vais pas capables de prendre
des responsabilités financières qui vont
peser sur la la collectivité pendant x
années non ça franchement c'est pas
possible le plus vite possible et qu'on
arrête l'hypocrisie sur ce sujet je
dick est un peu de tout le monde on n'en
parle pas il faut pas en parler c'est
gênant les français les français sont
pas dedans quand j'entends ça le
français sont pas dans les élections
non ils sont pas dans les élections mais
il ya des élections c'est comme ça c'est
la vie démocratique et donc il faut
respecter la vie des nomades
oui c'est un concours qui est de plus en
plus difficile est de plus en plus couru
il ya beaucoup de villes qui candidatent
et il y avait finalement 18 villes qui
avait été retenu en compétition des
grandes villes des capitales européennes
sofia budapest turin à turin et dans les
quatre villes finalistes
il ya aussi beaucoup de villes de
l'ancienne république soviétique la
lettonie l'estonie
donc là il ya tallinn qui a été retenu
dans les quatre ans les quatre villes
malgré le mauvais souvenir qui est cette
histoire et et puis il ya deux villes
françaises c'est la bonne nouvelle
grenoble et dijon et donc il y aura un
oral au mois de octobre je crois après
et on ira après j'irai défendre le
dossier de section ça serait un
formidable réussite c'est déjà une
formidable chance mais et compte sur vos
quoi de mieux que moi je suis un
compétiteur donc